bienvenidos de nuevo casi terminamos
esta sección
estamos en el problema 19 y dicen en una
embotelladora la máquina llena botellas
con agua mineral mientras que la máquina
ve acepta estas botellas solo si el
líquido está entre 11 enteros 7 octavos
de onza y 2 enteros y un octavo de onza
así que déjenme escribir esto que es
importante voy a poner aquí 11 enteros 7
octavos de onza y entre estos valores de
que está mi cantidad de onzas voy a
ponerle o x onzas no creo que se va a
confundir con 0 así que mejor voy a
ponerle x x de onza y aquí tiene que ser
menor que 12 enteros
está muy bien después dice el problema
si te acepta botellas que contengan en
la cantidad de líquido de onzas y en
lugar de equis le llaman n a las onzas
porque me preguntan cuál de las
siguientes afirmaciones describe los
posibles valores que puede tomar n así
que en lugar de x le voy a poner en en
lugar de x se va a llamar en la cantidad
de onzas y bueno aquí tengo cuatro
incisos y de estos cuatro incisos los
cuatro tienen que ver con valor absoluto
así que en lugar de escribirlos vamos a
pensar un poco en una afirmación en
valor absoluto si yo dibujo aquí un eje
mi eje de las bolsas y si este mismo eje
tiene por aquí el valor de cero vamos a
suponer que este es mi valor de cero ni
eje crece para acá y es mi eje de las
onzas y si por aquí está este de aquí es
11 enteros siete octavos y por otra
parte por acá no voy a tomar
el valor de dos enteros un octavo
entonces cuál es el punto medio entre
estos dos si te das cuenta entre 11
enteros 7 octavos y 2 enteros un octavo
hay dos octavos de diferencia de hecho
si sumamos en octavos once enteros siete
octavos más un octavo me da 12 este
punto de aquí va a ser 12 mientras que
si a este 2 le sumamos otro octavo me da
dos enteros un octavo y bueno date
cuenta que estamos hablando de
desigualdades estrictas porque esta
máquina acepta botellas solo si el
líquido está entre estos dos valores
sólo si el líquido está entre estos dos
valores ahora como estamos hablando del
valor absoluto lo que quiero que te
fijes es en distancia recuerda que una
forma de ver valor absoluto era la
distancia que había de un valor a otro
así que fíjate bien en esto esta
distancia que hay acá es un octavo
este valor y esta distancia que tengo de
aquí acá también es otro octavo justo
por eso el 2 está en medio y aquí no
tocamos este valor si la máquina acepta
botellas que tengan una cantidad de
onzas n entre estos dos valores entonces
mi cantidad de onzas podría ser ésta o
podría ser ésta o puede ser cualquier
cantidad entre estos dos valores lo que
quiere decir que la distancia que
tenemos que tener dna 12 es decir la
distancia que tenemos que tener de n a
12 y como es una distancia no voy a
poner en valor absoluto esto tiene que
ser menor que un octavo que estoy
diciendo aquí que si yo me fijo en la
distancia que hay de n a 12 esto tiene
que ser menor que un octavo porque si
fuera mayor que un octavo mes al día de
las posibilidades en las cuales mi
máquina ve acepta las botellas entonces
cualquier valor que tome aquí tiene que
ser menor que un octavo control y ver lo
podemos ver de la siguiente manera
si n es más grande que 12 entonces n 12
tiene que ser menor que un octavo
imagínate que yo te doy una cantidad de
onzas que sea mayor que 12 y bueno plan
menor que dos enteros un octavo y te doy
esta de aquí hasta que estoy dibujando
justo aquí entonces date cuenta que lo
más que puede valer la distancia que hay
de enea 12 es un octavo si es más grande
no lo va a aceptar la máquina ve y ahora
qué pasa si n es menor que 12 entonces n
menos 12 tiene que ser mayor que menos
un octavo estas dos expresiones al
juntarlas nos dan esta respuesta de aquí
que n 12 en valor absoluto sea menor que
un octavo la distancia que debe de haber
de 12 a la cantidad de onzas n tiene que
ser menor que un octavo porque si fuera
más grande que airea por acá y la
máquina b no me lo aceptaría y por
cierto
en un problema es mi inciso c así que
déjenme ponerlo aquí
este es el inciso c y bueno ya tengo
otro problema más así que vamos a
resolver el siguiente problema voy a
borrar mi pantalla y vamos a hacer el
problema número 20 perfecto ya casi
acabamos y dice el último entero de un
conjunto de enteros consecutivos es
menos 25 así que déjenme escribirlo aquí
el último entero es menos 25 y después
me dice si la suma de estos enteros
consecutivos es 26 déjame apuntar eso
también la suma es igual a 26 cuántos
enteros tiene nuestro conjunto el último
entero de un conjunto de enteros
consecutivos es menos 25
la suma es 26 cuántos enteros tienen
nuestro conjunto
a ver empezamos con menos 25 ya esto le
vamos a sumar algo y después le sumamos
otro algo y seguimos sumando y entonces
esto nos tiene que dar 26 cómo
resolvemos esto a ver vamos a ver si
tengo menos 25 ya esto de su modo le voy
a poner un entero 1 este va a ser me
entero 1 y después le sumó otro entero 2
y después le sumo y le sigo sumando y
sumando y sumando y llegó hasta un
entero n y eso tiene que ser igual a 26
y aquí se ve un poco raro esto porque a
ver qué pasa si sumo 25 de ambos lados
un entero uno más uno entero
todos estos de aquí es que tengo en
incógnitas más un entero n esto tiene
que ser igual a 26 más 25 porque este lo
voy a pasar del otro lado con signo
contrario es como si sumara 25 de ambos
lados de la ecuación y me queda 51 y
ahora tengo en incógnitas y una ecuación
a haber otra vez otra vez el último
entero de un conjunto de enteros
consecutivos es menos 25 el último
entero es igual a menos 25 de enteros
consecutivos claro es que aquí está la
clave son enteros consecutivos ahora se
me emprendió un poco el foco no no no
esto de aquí no le hagas caso es más
déjeme tachando a lo mejor lo voy a
borrar vamos a borrar todo esto que
escribí y no voy a quedar con esto con
que el último entero es igual a menos 25
personas enteros consecutivos déjenme
cambiar de color para ponerlo con otro
color más amigable
consecutivos y por lo tanto ya sé ya sé
mira qué pasa si yo me tomo la suma de
menos 25 ya esto le sumó menos 24 ya
esto le sumó menos 23 y me sigo sumando
y sumando y sumando hasta que llegó al
menos 3 ya éste le sumo menos 2 y éste
le sumo menos 1 y después le sumó 0 y
después empieza a sumar uno más dos más
tres y sigo sumando y sumando y sumando
y sumando y llegó al 23 y después a éste
le sumó 24 y después a éste le sumó 25
que voy a obtener la suma de todos estos
que tengo aquí pues date cuenta que va a
pasar algo padrísimo porque se van a
empezar a cancelar términos si yo sumo
25 y esto le quitó 25 esos no se van
si yo sumo 24 ya esto le restó 24 estos
dos también se van 23 menos 23 se van y
así sigue con sido cancelando
sigo cancelando hasta que llegó menos 33
estos dos se van también menos dos más
dos estos dos también se van y después
menos uno más uno estos dos también se
van y si sumo cero a cero pues voy a
obtener cero es decir que si yo me tomo
la suma desde menos 25 hasta 25 con
puros números consecutivos voy a obtener
de resultado 0 pero yo lo que quiero es
que la suma de 26 así que qué pasa si yo
me tomo la suma de menos 25 más todos
estos hasta menos 1 le sumó 0 le sumó 1
me tomo todavía la suma de todos estos
me llegó hasta 25 y ya que llegue a 25 a
esto le sumó 26 entonces este resultado
me va a dar pues todos estos se van a
cancelar y entonces mi resultado va a
ser 26 que es justo lo que yo quería que
la suma me diera 26 y entonces aquí
están ya todos
todos todos todos mis enteros de mi
conjunto cuántos son pues vamos a ver si
de aquí hasta acá es más vamos a verlo
desde la otra perspectiva de 1 a 25 de
aquí hasta acá todos estos son 25
enteros está de acuerdo y por otra parte
tengo de menos 1 hasta menos 25 y si te
das cuenta es la misma cantidad de
enteros que tengo aquí al lado estos
también son 25 enteros y ahora si yo le
sumó el 0 y después le sumó el 26
esto me dan 25 50 51 52 52 enteros en
total tiene mi conjunto de enteros del
cual no estaba refiriendo en este
problema que por cierto este es el
inciso e de este problema estaba en el
inciso m y qué creés hemos acabado esta
sección perfecto espero que te hayas
divertido y sigue divirtiendo así que
nos vemos en el siguiente
en la siguiente sección